Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I'm going
to explain an American psychological thriller
film called “Fractured.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Ray Monroe, with his wife Joanne and his daughter
Perri, is driving home from his in-law’s house.
It is the day of thanksgiving. The couple
argues about their relationship ,as Perri
sits in the backseat listening to music on her
headphones. Joanne begins to cry, knowing that
their marriage is at its ending. As they argue,
Perri’s headphones stop working, so the couple
stops arguing and sings songs with Perri to keep
her entertained. Sometime later, Perri has to go
to the bathroom. Ray pulls over at a gas station.
Joanne takes Perri to the washroom, as Ray goes
to buy batteries for Perri’s headphones,
coffee, and a coke for Joanne. However,
he is short on money, so he ditches the batteries
and gets two liquor bottles for himself.
Back in the car, he lies to Joanne, telling
her that the store did not have batteries.
Ray is about to start the car, when Perri notices
that her compact is missing. When they do not find
it in the car, Joanne goes to look for it
in the washroom. Ray gets up to check under
Perri’s seat but accidentally drops his coffee.
Perri is outside the car. As Ray is distracted,
Perri wanders off to a nearby construction
site. She sees a balloon and goes near it.
Just then, a dog comes near her; she starts
calling Ray for help. As Perri retreats, she
is stuck between the dog and a construction pit.
Ray finally notices the dog, and asks Perri not
to move and slowly tries to advert the dog’s
direction towards himself. Just as Ray throws
a stone at it, Perri gets scared and falls into
the pit. Ray runs to save her and falls into
the pit as well; he falls unconscious. He wakes
up a few seconds later and sees Joanne running
towards them. Perri lies unconscious beside
him, while Joanne checks her for injuries.
Ray is still in shock and doesn’t say anything.
Joanne comes to him crying hysterically,
but he pushes her aside. Ray closes his eyes,
and when he opens it, everything seems normal.
Perri opens her eyes, and he takes a sigh of
relief. However, her arm seems to be fractured,
so Ray gently picks Perri and takes her to the
car. Joanne suggests they call an ambulance,
but Ray claims to see a hospital nearby.
While they drive to the hospital,
Ray nearly crashes into another car. Perri lies in
the backseat with Joanne and is in a lot of pain.
When the family gets to the hospital, Joanne
and Perri sit in the waiting area as Ray
checks them in. The hospital is crowded, so the
receptionist tells him to wait for their turn.
As the three of them wait, Perri whimpers in pain.
Ray goes to the receptionist again and asks to be
sent earlier than others. However, she just makes
him sign paperwork and asks him to wait. He goes
back to his family in the waiting area, where
Joanne apologizes to him for being rude earlier.
After a while, the nurse calls Ray’s
name. The family is taken to a room,
where the nurse notes down required information
about them. The questions start to get intrusive,
which annoys the couple. The nurse then asks
them to register Perri as an organ donor, but
they refuse. Even after being denied, the nurse
pushes the topic, but Ray dismisses her. Another
nurse then takes them to a ward. Perri is put into
a hospital bed, and a doctor finally sees her.
He confirms that Perri’s arm is broken
and tells them that she needs a cast.
When the doctor finds out that Perri has also
hit her head, he advises them to do a CT scan.
The nurses cast Perri’s arm. She is then put
in a wheelchair and taken to the CT scan lab.
It turns out that only one parent can go to the
area at once, so Ray stays outside. Perri tells
him that she loves him before they part. Ray
falls asleep while waiting for them. He wakes up
in a few hours, and asks the receptionist about
his family, but since the shifts have changed,
she doesn’t know anything. She asks him
to wait while she checks the records.
It has been several minutes, but the receptionist
doesn’t say anything. Ray asks her again,
this time a little annoyed. She then checks the
morning record, but Perri’s name is not in it.
Frustrated, Ray asks to see the doctor who checked
Perri, but he has changed shifts too. Agitated,
Ray yells at the receptionist and bangs her desk,
so she immediately calls the CT room. However,
the person from the lab tells her that only
one old woman has come to the lab that day.
Ray is beyond frustrated; he angrily asks her
about his family, but the receptionist looks
at him as if he is crazy. She even blames
him for coming into the wrong hospital.
Ray insists that it is not possible, but she
ignores him and starts talking to someone else.
Worried about his family, Ray runs to the
restricted area of the hospital...only to be
stopped by the officials there. He informs them
of their visit this morning. The doctor checks
the day’s record but sees no patient by the name
of Monroe. Frustrated, Ray looks around and sees
the nurse who helped them earlier. The nurse
recognizes Ray. Believing that he has proved
his point, Ray sighs in relief, but the nurse
adds that she doesn’t know anything about his
daughter or his wife. According to her, Ray
came in for a head injury and was alone.
Agitated, Ray blames the nurse for lying. The
doctor assumes he has a contusion from his
head injury and offers to treat him. However, Ray
almost attacks the nurse and has to be restrained.
The doctor injects him with sedatives to calm him
down. He is then locked into a room by the guards;
Ray tries to unlock the door, but the drugs
make him hazy. To make the sedative not work,
he injects himself with an injection he finds
in the cabinets. He then tries to unlock the
door again, but it doesn’t work. Hence, he breaks
the glass door and runs out of the room. However,
before he can escape, people notice him running
away. The security chases him; but Ray somehow
manages to run out of the hospital and hide in his
car. A police car is right outside the hospital
too. Taking the opportunity, Ray stops the car
and tells the police about Joanne and Perri.
The police, suspecting that he is lying, ask
for identifiCTion. After he shows them his ID,
they agree to help him. The receptionist sees Ray
walk into the hospital again, but this time, she
cannot do anything because of the police officers.
She calls the security before assisting them.
The guards then let them in. Ray takes
the police to the doctor from earlier.
The doctor admits that there can be a mistake
in the records, and Ray demands they be taken
to the CT lab. The doctor agrees; however, the
guards take them to the third floor; Ray clearly
remembers the CT lab being in the basement.
At the lab, it is clear that Perri was
never there. Ray then demands to call doctor
Berthram, who had checked Perri that morning.
The staff obliges. Just then, the receptionist
comes in with the paper that Ray had signed this
morning. However, it doesn’t prove the presence of
Joanne and Perri. Doctor Berthram finally arrives,
and reveals that Ray came to the hospital
alone to get treated for his head injury.
The doctor had asked him to do a CT scan,
but he refused, saying that his wife Abby
was waiting for him outside. The police officers
get suspicious of Ray because he has told them
that his wife’s name is Joanne; not Abby.
Ray then reveals that Abby is his ex-wife,
who has been dead for years. Helpless, Ray
accuses the hospital of kidnapping his family.
The security guard suggests they look at the
CCTV camera footage to see if Ray is lying.
The group then watches the footage for the
morning, but Perri and Joanne are in none of them.
Ray claims that it is because of the camera’s
angle. The police officers do not believe Ray’s
story anymore. Ray then asks them to go to the
gas station to figure the truth. He even finds
Perri’s scarf near the hospital bed she was in the
morning. He claims that this proves she was here,
but the police need more evidence than that. The
doctors suspect that Ray is not in a mentally
stable condition, so they introduce him to a
psychiatrist named Teresa Jacobs. Teresa takes
Ray to a room and shows him his administration
record, which doesn’t mention Perri or Joanne.
Teresa calmly talks to him and inquires about
the incidents of that morning. She also asks him
about Abby. Ray then reveals that Abby died eight
years ago in a car accident, and he couldn’t save
her because he was drunk. Frustrated, he starts
to cry. Teresa now knows for sure that something
is wrong. She suggests the police go look at
the place the accident occurred this morning.
According to Teresa, Joanne and Perri might still
be there. The police officers then take Ray and
Teresa to the construction site again. They
call for backup to help them with the search.
Then they find Perri’s compact on the pit. They
also see a pool of dried blood in the concrete.
The police realize that this cannot be Ray’s
blood, because his injury isn’t that bad. The
missing people and the blood make the officers
realize that the place is a crime scene.
However, Ray, in turn, blames the police officers
for planting the compact and the blood to falsely
accuse Ray. He believes that the police want
to save the hospital for what they have done
to Joanne and Perri. Teresa, on the other hand,
tries to calm Ray down and asks him what happened
to Perri. Ray starts to blabber. Teresa then
asks him if he pushed Perri down the pit.
This makes Ray go silent. He doesn’t
move and stares into the distance.
The police then arrest him on the suspicion of
killing his wife and his daughter. As they are
about to handcuff him, Ray snaps. He snatches
the officer’s gun and points it at Teresa.
Then, he makes them go into the gas station
and locks them there. Taking Teresa’s key card,
Ray drives to the hospital in a police
car. He hides the gun and goes inside.
His plan is to go to the basement, where he
believes that Joanne and Perri are captured.
While he is at it, he comes across the maternity
room. The children remind him of the day Abby
died. He reminisces of the death which had
killed both Abby and his unborn kid.
He somehow manages to get a doctor’s apron
and disguises himself as one. He gets into
the elevator and is about to go to the basement,
but the security guard from earlier joins him.
He and Ray get into a fight. In the end, Ray
strangles the guard to death and takes his keys.
Ray is finally in the basement of
the hospital. As he looks around,
he finds Perri’s toy in a bin nearby. Sure
that his daughter is somewhere near, he takes
the gun in his hand and searches for her.
Then, he sees two doctors delivering boxes
of human organs somewhere. Ray finally realizes
that Joanne and Perri were brought here to get
their organs harvested. This explains the nurse
trying to make Perri an organ donor that morning.
Ray then enters a room, and is horrified to see
several dead bodies with missing organs. He rushes
out of the room looking for Perri, and finally
finds her in another room being operated on by
surgeons. Joanne is in the corner of the room,
highly sedated. The doctors had drugged her.
Ray then holds the surgeons at gunpoint, and
places both Joanne and Perri in a wheelchair.
But before he can run away, the doctors restrain
him. They are about to inject him with drugs,
but Ray manages to free himself by
shooting a device and causing an explosion.
Ray finally runs out of the room with
both Joanne and Perri in the wheelchair.
He kills another doctor in the hallway.
He brings his family out of the hospital
and puts them in the backseat of his car. The
family finally drives away to their home. Perri
tells them that her arm still hurts, so Ray sings
her a song to make her feel better. Just then,
the camera pans to the back seat, and we see that
the people sitting there are two random people
that Ray has kidnapped from the middle of their
surgery. Ray gets flashbacks from the morning,
and we get to know that Perri died when she fell
into the pit. When Ray pushed Joanne, he killed
her as well. Ray’s mind couldn’t handle the pain
of him being the reason for his family’s death.
Hence, his mind constructs a new reality in
which both his wife and daughter are still alive.
Ray believes he is rescuing them, but it is
revealed that he has kidnapped a random patient
from surgery. Joanne and Perri’s dead bodies were
inside the trunk of his car the whole time.
The movie ends as Ray hallucinates Joanne
telling him to take them home. And that's
the heartbreaking ending of the movie!
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave
a like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.